Congressman Maxine Waters is leading the
Democratic charge this fall her weapon
of choice is rage in a speech last
weekend she vowed that Democrats would
impeach not simply President Trump but
once they finished doing that vice
president Mike Pence as well watch this
deplorable despicable human being that
occupies the White House should not be
there we they say Maxine please don't
say impeachment anymore
and when they say that I say impeachment
impeachment when someone asks but what
about pets if you were able to impeach
pets will be worse and I said look keep
in mind if Democrats win in two months
Maxine Waters will be a committee
chairman mark pan was a pollster and
strategist for Bill Clinton and he joins
us tonight so mark you were I mean you
spent a lot of time thinking about
messages who's in charge of the
democratic message do you think well
that's a good question there doesn't
seem to be either a democratic message
or particularly a Republican message as
we go into this yes other than you know
Trump's Trump's no good and we've got to
put guardrails on him and the Democrats
have moved too far to the left and one
more feature that's what passes for a
serious message today if you're the
Democrats though wouldn't you look at
the last election and say let's see a
lot of former Democrats voted for Trump
because they felt left behind by the
economy maybe we should try to win their
votes back no one seems to be doing that
why well look I think that this is going
on on individual races Maxine Waters is
talking to Democratic base voters who
are 90 percent going to vote you know
for the Democratic column and she's
trying to stimulate turnout that's not
what's happening in real swing districts
where I think there's a battle between
the candidates there's a battle over the
health care issue that the Democrats I
think won handily and so I think they
put that front and center there's some
serious issue debates out there we just
don't really see them because they don't
make news does it it seems to me that if
you're you know watching at home and
there's a congressional race and there
is where you live you look at Maxine
Waters and you think boy
I don't want anything to do with the
party that puts her forward as a
spokesman I mean is that kind of
productive do you think since we now
have television and we can all see what
she's saying
well Maxine Waters is counterproductive
for the overall Democratic message but
she's not a key Democratic leader in
fact the Republican leaders McConnell
and Ryan Ryan has quit but then he
didn't leave McConnell is intensely
disliked if you look at Schumer and
Pelosi within the party they actually
have the support of Democrats in terms
of what they want to do Republicans
right now have no leader outside a
president Trump no that is absolutely
true Republicans do not like Paul Ryan I
would say by and large who's gonna be a
speaker if Democrats win well look i
think Pelosi probably will win in the
first instance but I don't think she'll
show continue to serve I think then
there will be a struggle behind the
scenes I think there's a problem solvers
group that is looking to have some
influence if it's close in terms of
changing the rules and naming the
speaker because remember the speaker
technically has to be elected by a
majority vote of the house not the
majority vote of a caucus
so you think Pelosi will get if the
Democrats win Pelosi will be elected
Speaker but then not serve look I don't
think she's gonna serve through to the
next election my suspicion would be she
would get elected because she won she
turned the house but but between then
and the next election there there'd be a
new Speaker I think that the Democratic
Party is looking is looking to have new
blood and new leadership the question is
where and who the last question I mean
there are a bunch of adults in the
Democratic Party I know them they live
near me they seem afraid of the Netroots
of democratic activists online or way
out to the left from where they
traditionally have been do they have the
power and the will to stand up to those
constituencies and say no I'm sorry
we're not making this Venezuela you know
no or they some do and some don't I mean
remember that because of the caucuses in
the Democratic primaries the activists
have outsize power compared to the
run-of-the-mill voter in big states
which really
most democratic voters and so you see
embarrassing performances like Senator
Cory Booker playing for the presidential
race but I think you look at what Joe
Biden is doing and he's tends to be
pitching to the responsible center so
far he's got the best message and shown
the greatest responsibility out there on
the stump yeah mark Penn great to see
you thank you very much for that